Kristopher what about making the
documentary tiny helped to become a
better filmmaker what did you learn from
that experience wow so much tiny was
definitely for me a boot camp and really
and filmmaking but also particularly
making documentaries from everything
from the actual process of you know
shooting and editing and you know doing
sound and those things but also from the
business side of things in terms of
raising money and distribution and its
own festival circuit and learning about
festival strategy all the way through
running your own business so I mean I
learned so many things it's a you know I
can't even keep enough time to go over
it really well you'd said earlier
off-camera that the design communities
is a very enthusiastic community and
then it's a large group I think did you
think that they would take to the film
as they did I mean it's one of our most
watched videos from when we interviewed
you so did you think that they would
just be so taken by it when we first you
know set out to do tiny at night you
know we didn't really know what to
expect and it certainly exceeded any
sort of expectation that we had for the
project initially but we along the way
saw how people were reacting to it you
know so when we the first time it kind
of went public as a project was when we
did Kickstarter and seeing how that took
off and you know how before we even
finished the movie we had something like
seven hundred eight hundred Facebook
followers for it and you know we we
could tell that there was something
there and the interest in the media all
along and just the way that things would
get you know would be shared or go viral
or things like that and you know it got
to the point where we would talk to a
new reporter or whoever and we'd say you
know just so you know you're a lot of
people are gonna read your article or
whatever and they've course everybody
always does that and then we get an
email like a week to the day later like
this was like the most read article that
we'd ever had and I'm like telogen you
know I'd like to pretend that that was
because marette and I were very charming
and they really cared about her story
but in reality I think that we just
really timed it well and that the
tiny-house phenomenon it was
basically as if you know there's just a
whole bunch of dried hay and somebody
lit a match and we just happened to
really time it perfectly and that and
the interest in that kind of design in
particular in simple living was that
just at the right place but I have since
learned you know through that process
that you know having communities that
are interested in the topic of your film
as a documentary filmmaker is really
helpful you know and and particularly
because communities are you know it's
basically a what does it call like a
lateral community where it's a bunch of
people who choose to like you know
associate because of something that they
share like a like an interest rather
than like a geographic location and
those communities can really like propel
your projects forward and I know Jay
Shafer had been around for a long time
with tumbleweed I think that's a yeah
although he now has his own company
called for Lights dance company oh okay
yes so then from what you learned in
terms of looking back what would you not
repeat in terms of maybe of a planning
perspective technical even getting into
film festivals what were some things
that you plan to do differently with I
know you have many projects you want to
be involved in so what did it teach you
in that sense I think you know honestly
is not to sound you know I guess
slightly arrogant or everybody but we
actually didn't really make dumb any
mistakes which we very easily could have
but we were very we had a lot of good
mentors who kind of steered us in the
right direction I would say that if
they're I think some of the bigger
mistakes though were I wouldn't know I
don't know if this is necessarily a
mistake but we set out to make a short
film and so when we decided to make a
longer film there was some things that
we didn't film in the beginning that I
would have with going into it with that
knowledge and so when we tried to make a
future like a like a longer future we
know 80 minutes long or whatever we've
realized that
the material we had can really make a
compelling narrative of that length and
so we ended up scaling it back to you 62
minutes which ended up being the right
the right fit for the movie and it
worked great however in terms of
distribution no one is going to
distribute a film less than 74 ish
minutes so it really automatically ruled
out any sort of all rights deals that we
might have had with some of the you know
bigger dock distributors who initially
were interested but ultimately didn't do
because they couldn't do with theatrical
release well that leads me to my next
and also last question about tiny and
just that is that
did you receive millions of views on
like Netflix and Hulu and iTunes and how
were you able to verify that right so
you can't they won't tell you in terms
of s VOD subscription video on demand
they won't tell you how many views you
have but we I can say that I have sort
of pieced together that there I would
guess if I were estimating anywhere from
five to maybe as much as thirty million
views on Netflix alone and the way that
I came to that assessment and that's
what I've been stolen white range so
obviously I don't know that much but
back before Netflix changed their layout
they used to have the star ratings and
underneath the star ratings it would
tell you how many people gave it a star
rating and I think when ours went before
they write when they remodel is the last
time I looked it was like five hundred
and sixty thousand star ratings which
you know is for documentaries actually
is like really high most tub we're
having around fifty thousand and if you
can assume and I mean I don't really
know what the real number is but I
imagine only maybe one out of ten people
actually take the trouble to like rain
raid a movie I mean so ten times that
would be five million but it could be as
high as twenty meeting that you we don't
really know since then I had a meeting
at Netflix and I'd tried to ask him I
was like do you know how many views me
and of course the another person I was
talking with was like it's like I can't
tell you that but I can tell you that it
had a lot more than my friends movie
and her and she had a lot or so I don't
know something like that I was like okay
so that's the closes I'm gonna get to an
answer but it it was a lot and I mean
even like one time we actually found a
pirated copy of tiny on on YouTube and I
had something like 70,000 views and Wow
well if the pirated YouTube version of
70,000 and we can assume that's a non
pirated version you know had more so I
think it's still on Hulu and I had a
friend to work at who the who also said
that it was doing pretty well but I
don't know and it didn't come out on
Huell until like two years or maybe a
year and a half after is on Netflix so I
don't really know what the numbers are
but I assume that all if you included
all of the views everywhere it would
probably be in the tens of millions
you